well for her breakthrough performance in
the unbelievably popular good morning
miss bliss Hayley Mills got her start
with Disney in the classic film The
Parent Trap the story two identical twin
girls are separated at birth but then
coincidentally meet up at a summer camp
at first they're offended that the other
dare look like the other one and they
try playing practical jokes on each
other but after a while they start to
talk to each other more and identify
with one another and find out that there
are actually sisters so they decide to
step things up a bit and switch places
one daughter finally meeting her father
for the first time and the other finally
meeting her mother for the first time
eventually has revealed what happened
and the mother and the father get
together and try to decide what to do
while that's going on the girls try to
set a trap a Parent Trap if you will to
try and get them back together
this is especially tricky seeing how the
father is marrying another woman who of
course is a stick-in-the-mud who never
knows how to have fun and always needs
her comeuppance to be given to her by
well our two main heroes this is
definitely not a movie like Darby O'Gill
or Davy Crockett where there's big
adventures or anything like that it's a
much smaller past story and a smaller
stories go it's okay it kept my interest
I want to know what was gonna happen and
at the time the split-screen technology
was unbelievable but now it's kind of
obvious really the focus of the movie is
on Hayley Mills who does a great job as
both girls and what makes it so good is
that you know distinctly their
personalities and which one is wit but
it's never overplayed it's not like one
is super mean and super harsh and the
other is like a complete angel they're
both still real girls with real problems
and well real personalities and that's
tough to do for a child actor and she
pulls it off really well
I'm personally never a fan of those
romantic comedies where they're gonna
marry the snob and you know they
shouldn't be together and they go back
and forth whether or not the couple you
know is gonna get together is really
gonna get together it drives me nuts
I think that's partially why I like the
first half of this movie much more than
like the second half where it actually
is focusing again the parents together
the father mother do make a good couple
it's just oh why do we have to
that cliched character there uh at least
to this movies credit this was done long
before this was repeated over and over
and say wedding crashers and other
romantic comedies so I guess you can
give it a little leeway there too on the
whole I see the movie is kind of a cute
waste of time
there's nothing of that much value to it
but there's nothing I feel like I've
really lost it just kind of is what it
is a cute little movie about two girls
who look alike turned out her sisters
they share their emotions do girly
things get in trouble and mishaps and
it's fine for what it is it's just not a
film I'm gonna be watching over and over
and over because I like it so much but
once wasn't bad I just think that's all
I need if you got the time and you just
want to see a charming little film with
a charming little child actress this
isn't a bad one to check out